Donald Trump's alleged role in paying
hush money to a porn star could soon
lead to criminal charges against the
former president a first in U.S history
exclusive articles The Wall Street
Journal published in 2018 triggered this
investigation into Trump and reporter
Joe Palazzolo is still digging I did not
expect five years later to be still
talking about this case at all as a
grand jury is concluding its
investigation let's look at the
reporting that led to this pivotal
moment and what could come next
let's start in 2016. days before Trump's
election victory
and years before porn star Stormy
Daniels would tell her side in prime
time and you had sex with him yes
you were 27 he was 60 were you
physically attracted to him no not at
all no during the 2016 campaign Daniels
and her manager were shopping her story
of an alleged affair with Trump from a
decade earlier she'd been unsuccessful
celebrity magazines and tablets didn't
want to buy it Michael Cohen Trump's
personal lawyer at the time was also
approached with an offer to buy Daniel's
story that was in September Cohen says
go to hell essentially no and then
Access Hollywood happens and when you're
started they let you do it you can do
anything whatever you want grab them by
the and then boom it's like a 180.
stormy's lawyer is back on the phone
with Cohen and they're hashing out a
deal Daniels agrees to a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars for her story in
exchange for her silence and signs a
contract on October 28 2016. Journal
reporters caught wind of Daniels around
this time and over months work to piece
the story of the payment together so the
first story ran in January 2018 it was
pretty Bare Bones I mean what we said is
what we knew which is the Michael Cohen
had arranged 130 000 payment to stormy
Daniel and so we had confirmed that he'd
use the Delaware limited liability
company a shell company essentially to
transfer the payment and so those are
the two stories that we reported in 2018
that really got the ball rolling a
political Firestorm erupted Trump denied
the affair and knowledge of the payment
Days Later FBI agents raided Cohen's
home which Trump called disgraceful
situation it's a total Witch Hunt I've
been saying it for a long time Federal
prosecutors charged Cohen with campaign
Finance violations and other federal
crimes he pleaded guilty to all of the
charges telling a federal judge at the
time that Trump had directed him to buy
Daniel silence I am providing the
committee today with several documents
and these include
a copy of a check Mr Trump wrote from
his personal bank account after he
became president
to reimburse me for the hush money
payments I made to cover up his affair
with an adult film star and to prevent
damage to his campaign despite Cohen
implicating Trump in the crime Federal
prosecutors dropped the case but that
still left the possibility of State
charges as the Trump organization is
based in New York Cyrus fans the
Manhattan district attorney stepped in
ultimately the DA's office decided not
to bring charges when Vance retired the
new D.A Alvin Bragg initially decided
not to pursue the hush money
investigation there is a felony of
falsifying business records charge but
that requires the records to have been
falsified and to conceal another crime
or to commit another crime and you know
the obvious other crime here is the
campaign Finance crime the actual payoff
of Stormy Daniels to protect Donald
Trump's campaign but
there has never been a case or a judge a
state judges has never blessed the use
of felony falsifying business records
premised on a federal charge in other
words these are State prosecutors
they're bringing a state charge and in
order to elevate it to a felony they
have to say that the crime that was
concealed by falsifying these business
records was a federal crime so that's
like a weird thing and they decided it
was going to be too risky to bring a
case that was going to rely on an
untested legal Theory but then in
January Bragg impaneled a new grand jury
to investigate the payments he hasn't
said publicly why he changed course
everyone's surprised frankly because our
reporting and others had shown that the
office had looked at this so many times
had looked at it through kind of
different lenses and decided each time
not to bring it the feds had passed up
on the chance to bring it so now here we
are in 2023 and what's changed I mean we
don't we don't really know yet one thing
that hasn't changed is Cohen's
involvement Trump's former lawyer
testified before the grand jury last
week and could be called to speak with
them again this is all about
accountability
held accountable for his Dirty Deeds
Trump has denied the affair and any
wrongdoing calling the investigation
politically motivated the Manhattan DA's
office did not respond to requests for
comment if Bragg brings charges against
the former president it could shine more
light on what happened in 2016. and the
Diamonds just an allegation right there
are still you know questions that I have
even after having worked on this for so
long if the charges are focused on
falsifying business records you know
like what did Trump know about repaying
Cohen there's a lot of sort of gaps in
our knowledge about how this all went
down and then you know I'm really
curious to see if the DA has like
learned some new facts charges if they
come I think would would sort of begin
like just one more chapter
foreign